hey y'all I'm JP and I'm Sarah and we
are PhD students at the University of
North Carolina at Chapo
Hill as you can imagine in North
Carolina there's a lot of different
Farmers Market the carb Farmers Market
is 2 minutes away from where I
live now I go here every Saturday and
what I've learned is the food just
tastes so much better when you get to
know the farmer uh when you get to know
the
farmer JP recently took me to my first
farmers market and there it was a lot of
fun but it was really overwhelming at
first because there was so much going on
I didn't know who to talk to or what to
say or even where to start and this
reminded me a lot of when I started
coding in r i was faced with this
beautiful wall of hex codes but I wasn't
sure how they worked or where to start
or what to do once I loaded a package it
wasn't until recently that I realized
behind each of these packages is a
person that really wants you to succeed
in using that
package even though it can be a little
bit intimidating still to reach out to
these people and know what to
say so I've had some success doing this
on my podcast from where does it stem
where I interview scientists from all
over the world and ask them how they got
there I've interviewed people like Jane
Goodall uh the director of the NIH
Francis Collins Tony Fouch boss and our
boy Hadley
wiam I asked them questions about their
bringings how they got to where they are
what their favorite songs are and also
how they think stem or science can be
more
inclusive so for this year's posit
conference we decided to ask some local
r/ bioconductor celebrities some
questions we did video interviews with
two of them to give you an idea of how
these conversations might go Jo and
Winston if you're here I'd turn around
if you don't like seeing yourself on the
big screen um so hey big Winston and Joe
tell us about the positive Community it
is really nice to be in in a community
where there's uh a lot of people coming
from a lot of different places and you
know everyone gets along yeah in terms
of like inclusiveness uh you know that
that is something that was very
intentional there's also uh other users
groups like there like like our ladies I
mean those things just sort of developed
organically so you know there there
people involved in that did a really
great job every time I have um an
interaction with someone who who like
not only has appreci for what the
software does but what it's allowed them
to do to become as a person and
especially if that
[Music]
person feels like this is a space that
they didn't necessarily feel like they
might be welcomed um it it is just
incredibly motivating for for me and for
us uh to go out and do our best work uh
year after
year Winston has his head down over
there all right cool cool cool Winston
and Joe what are some things you do
outside of package development in
periods in the past I've done
photography um pretty intensely I also
do some woodworking I uh love cycling I
don't get to do it as much as I would
like to but um it's definitely a nice
antidote to uh you know I feel like I
cram my brain full at oric and then
cycling lets me sort of like
release and on a great smile yes and
thanks again to you guys for talking to
us and we found everyone we reached out
to was really receptive to just chatting
and answering questions about their life
and what they do outside of
coding but the posit Community is so
much more than just these developers it
also involves everyone in this room and
everyone watching this video I found the
strongest connection through joining my
lab with two graduate students there at
the time Nicole and Eric they now have
their phds and are off doing wonderful
things but at the time they were devel
veloping their own R packages to do some
biological research so I got hands-on
experience and got to contribute to
these packages and not only am I
extremely lucky to call these guys my
friends but they also let me U have the
confidence to create my own package
which is under
development if you don't have your own
team of people that you can meet with
every day there are some great resources
through the posit community and their
website as well things like coming to
this conference or checking out YouTube
channel going to data science Hangouts
and commenting there and being a part of
it or joining one of these user groups
like rladies or the r for data science
learning community yeah we got some
representation here um and the rord data
science Community also runs the Tidy
Tuesday if you've ever done that or want
to challenge yourself with it so
hopefully we have planted a seed today
to inspire you to
connect with the community and the
people around you and use those
connections to challenge yourself to do
something outside your comfort Zone to
give you the confidence to create
something new whether it be a package a
workflow or your own unique
project if you're interested in checking
out the podcast here's a Spotify code if
you want to reach out to Sarah and I
please do here our emails we'd love to
interview some people for the podcast
and for ye's interview and Mike loves
feel free to scan this QR code thank you
thank
you